SALMAN KHAN: Now that
students can get access
to the information delivery part
of learning-- the lectures--
at their own time
and their own pace,
and we also have an
interactive portion where
they can do problems,
a lot of teachers
are saying, well, why should
I use the scarce class
time for this kind of passive,
I lecture, people listen, take
notes?
Instead, we could use that
for actual interactivity.
And it's different
for every teacher.
It's different for
every classroom.
But we've seen classrooms now
where when they come to class,
they're doing problem solving.
And they have the teacher
there to help them out,
to tutor them.
And they have their peers too.
And the classes a
lot of us grew up in,
if you wanted to help your
peer, you'd get in trouble.
You know, shh, be quiet, listen.
But now it's like no, no.
This is what it's all about--
getting help from your peers,
doing problem solving,
doing open-ended projects,
interacting with your teacher.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: What do you
think your average-- maybe
that's not the way to put it.
How do you think a lot
of classes are failing?
I mean, what's wrong with
the American education
system in a typical
classroom, where it really
isn't serving a student today?
SALMAN KHAN: Yeah,
and then this is
something I go into a lot
of detail on in the book.
All of the paranoia
about our school system,
we come look at the
national rankings,
we're like, oh,
we're behind Estonia
in factoring polynomials.
It's the end of the world.
America's going to
lose everything.
And one thing--
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: We're kind
of low on science and math.
SALMAN KHAN: Low on
science and math.
And we shouldn't get
complacent about that.
But one thing I point out is if
you look at the last 50 years,
and you look at the
innovation in the world,
it's only been that
getting more and more
concentrated in the US.
If you look at the most
innovative companies--
the Facebooks, the
Googles, the Twitters--
they're all coming from America.
And part of is because we're
the most creative countries.
It's innovative.
Failure isn't stigmatized.
And so instead of this model
of education that we have,
where all the students
are batched together
and there are passive lecturers,
and they're pushed forward?
This is a model inherited
from Prussia, a country that
does not exist
anymore, 200 years ago.
And so what I point
out instead of trying
to compare our Prussian model to
the Prussian model in Singapore
and the Prussian model
in Finland, all of which
are passive models, we should
make our model more American.
Make it interactive when
people come to the classroom.
Give room for creativity.
If you get a C or a D,
it's not about failure.
It's about, well,
make it better then.
MALE SPEAKER: I find this
fascinating in the context
of something else, which is like
the idea of stereotyped threat.
And this is this idea that
sometimes in classrooms,
some kids feel like there's a
threat response that they will
be stereotyped if
they ask questions
when they don't
understand something.
So the idea that
you could go back
and-- you don't understand that
you could listen to it again
on your own and then
seek help at another time
or in your own pace.
So girls sometimes
feel this threat
when they're in math classes.
They found that
African Americans
feel this threat a lot of
times in classes in general,
that they feel like
they're asking questions
that they shouldn't be asking.
And therefore, they don't do it.
And this seems like it gets
around that whole concept.
Am I right about that?
SALMAN KHAN: No, no.
You're hitting, I
think, the core problem.
When people say, oh, but in
lecture, I can ask questions.
I was like, no.
Three people have the
guts to ask a question.
And if you're in an algebra
class and you forgot how
to multiply decimals,
or you forgot--
you don't even know your, maybe
you don't-- and we've see this
is in some algebra classes.
There's no way you're going to
raise your hand and say, wait,
I forgot my fourth grade math.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: OK.
You've taught more
classes on Khan Academy
than Harvard University has
offered since its founding.
What is your vision for
future of education globally?
SALMAN KHAN: We want
to keep growing, get
to hundreds of
millions of students.
We've translated our
content into 12 languages.
It's being used
around the world.
We want to become
more interactive.
And we hope that the
conversation isn't just
about-- a lot of the,
within this Prussian model,
how do we tweak the system?
But it's about time.
It's been 200 years,
and we can actually
fundamentally rethink the model.
So it's not this passive system.
It's much more.